les taux d'incidence le taux d'incidence
à paris s'établit aujourd'hui à 326
nouveaux cas par semaine pour cent mille
habitants
la moyenne nationale s'élève à 222 sur
la même période
la situation est certes moins grave que
dans les alpes maritimes on a ici les
tableaux qui montrent notamment la
situation de toutes les grandes
métropoles mais elle reste très
préoccupante et elle pourrait on le sait
devenir alarmante dans les prochains
jours le variant britanniques
représentaient plus de 60% des tests
positifs il y a dix jours or la pression
sur l'hôpital est déjà très forte avec
plus de 72 % des lits de réanimation qui
sont occupés par des patients qu'ovide
cette pression s'accroît de façon
continue depuis le 20 février en février
paris a aussi connu un surcroît de
mortalité de 20 % par rapport au mois de
février 2010 9 et sur les trois derniers
mois le co vide a tué plus de personnes
que de mars à août 2020 ça veut dire que
cette deuxième vague ou avec son
prolongement de troisième vague et
terriblement meurtrière